[Music]
so hi I'm Daniel LeMay I am a developer
at these two technology and I am here to
talk to you about graph QL and how it
can help improve your api's and as well
as make them more discoverable and a joy
to use to your front-end developers out
of curiosity who has heard of graph QL
most everyone who's actually used it
even think so about half of the people
who've heard about it all right so I
know when I first got into graph QL and
started looking to it like it was seemed
like this big
ominous scary thing and a lot of people
that I've talked to of like Oh graph
kula that's like really complicated like
I don't know if I can get into it well
it's not so I'm hope to kind of give an
introductory overview of what it is and
what some of the problems that it solves
are and give you some tools to get
started with it if that's something that
you're interested in so first I want to
talk about something that I don't think
we always keep in mind and that's
latency because a lot of us as
developers were really good internet
speeds
we've got either on a wired connection
or really good Wireless so here's just
some average latency 'z so average
latency this is just to get your network
requests going wired connection point
three milliseconds that's pretty darn
fast Wi-Fi connection three milliseconds
we're already in order of magnitude
higher 4G which we've got pretty good 4G
coverage especially if you're in good
metropolitan areas now we're already at
64 milliseconds 3G or up to 152
milliseconds now as we develop more
mobile first and keeping in mind the
international market like we need to
keep this in mind and it's something
that can be really easily overlooked
because hey it runs fast for me but a
lot of people are consuming things on
their phones
the there they're nowhere near even
there even their Wi-Fi connection so
Russ has this good thing and this bad
problem that comes with so here's a
sample API request response from the LP
API this is all of the data that gives
me for one singular business it's a lock
which is exactly how rest is designed
you give me this endpoint I'll give you
all of the details about this business
or hit this endpoint and I'll give you
an array of businesses that meet meet
this category like that's exactly what
rest is supposed to do problem again
keeping in mind mobile is this is a lot
of over fetching like you have seriously
increased payload and it only further
exacerbates itself when I now need to
take some of this data and make another
API call so I have to wait for this data
to get back
fine pull out that piece of data make
another API call still having that
latency effect sometimes you get to
three Brown trips like it can can really
start to bog things down and if I'm
looking at that API as a front-end
developer because I do most of my work
is front-end like it just gives me a
giant migraine so here's a sample API
structure for a really basic block so
we've got users who can create blog so I
have the user API endpoint this is
obviously somewhat contrived like I'm
not trying to build the most robust API
example in the world
so slash user gives me the user object
which also has an array of posts that
they've created then we have posts which
returns me all of the posts that they've
created I'm sure we can add some
agitation in there to make it more
efficient and then posts will give me
all the data for just a specific post so
let's say I want to create an index of
said posts I'd probably hit the user API
get the array of posts or get their ID
then hit the post API with their user ID
to get all of their posts everything oh
I really care
is the title the slug maybe an excerpt
like I don't need all of that data but
I'm gonna get it because that's what
rest does it gives it to you whether you
like it or not so that's where graph QL
comes in so according to graph QL org
that's a specification graph QL is a
query language for api's and a runtime
for fulfilling those queries with your
existing data so a couple things that
graph QL is not it is not a framework is
not language specific you can integrate
it with most major programming languages
and I have a link in the resources slide
at the end that you can say oh I want to
build a front-end I want to build a
back-end here's the language it'll give
you all the libraries that you can use
so graph QL is a specification it was
written by Facebook to fulfill their
increasing graph data needs and all
these interconnected queries and to find
a more efficient way to get the data
that they need so graph QL org you can
find the actual specification there and
then there's multiple frameworks that
have built up several layers of
abstraction to make it a whole lot
easier to use so key things first what
problems does graph QL solve and you
have huge impacts on your performance so
you decrease your payload size because
you're only getting the data that you
need and it reduces the number of round
trips because I'm no longer waiting for
data to come back on the client and then
making another request I'm getting all
of the data that I need back in the
single request all of the fetching and
all the looping is handled on the server
it increases developer experience
through automatic documented api's which
is amazing
who here has tried to use a horribly
documented API yeah that's no fun or the
documentation is out of date or
something
changed non-existent even better yeah
just just great fun throwing the
computer out the window so graph QL
includes amazing documentation
out-of-the-box and updates as you build
your API you're no longer relying on
someone to maintain documentation using
a system like swagger to document your
API it's just included and that's
because of how it's set up
it also has deep integration with modern
front-end JavaScript so react view all
of the modern frameworks I think angular
also has some plugins for it which
include caching which reduces their need
to even fetch data from the backend
which again further increases
performance so how do we do this so
graph QL creates a declarative data
structure so you declare all of the
different fields that your data
structure has and what types they are so
if you aren't familiar with type systems
like this is this is gonna be kind of
new it's not all loose and fancy free
like Java scripts as we generally think
of it you can connect different data
sources in the same query so let's say I
need to get some from a database some
from a third party API endpoint
something from a lambda function you can
include all of those in your your graph
QL server through the resolvers you also
only have one endpoint which as a
front-end developer like that makes me
so happy I don't have to deal with
environment variables of like oh I'm in
dev so I need to have this URL for this
endpoint here and I'll change it to this
URL in production and have to tie it all
of my react component codes to all of
these ridiculous URLs and oh that the
URL change like you don't have to deal
with any of that yeah you set up one one
URL and then all the queries all of the
mutations run through the one URL it's
amazing it also enables really good
mocking so
you're developing your back-end and your
front-end right alongside of each other
you can set up pay here's what the data
store looks like and you can plug in
mock resolvers for the front-end and
well pretend like they're actually
getting real data from the backend even
if the backend isn't set up yet and then
when the backend is already to live you
just pull off that line of code and you
hook it up to the real back-end and we
already talked about client caching a
little bit so graph QL uses types so
vanilla JavaScript is loosely typed for
better or worse like it's one of those
things that people either love or hate I
will say that after you getting into a
graph QL I really dislike loosely typed
JavaScript and I've gone full in on
using flow so with vanilla JavaScript
you can have loose equality the string
of one equals one that's going to render
true and the string of one with strict
equality it's one it's going to equal
false so when you're using loose
equality it's using type coercion to
determine this the values are equal
graph QL uses strict typing so there's
no coercion so you can't do any loose
equality it basically treats everything
like with strict equality you declare
your field types on the server if
there's any mismatches whatsoever it's
gonna throw an error like it gives you
no wiggle room which sounds intimidating
but then you don't actually have to
worry about the structure of your data
you're gonna get exactly the structure
of your data that you declare which
makes development really really nice and
you can also declare the field is
knowable or non knowable so default
types that you get with graphic you all
in the spec out-of-the-box you have a
string an integer float boolean an ID ID
is really just a string but it Flags it
in graph QL terms as something that is
not meant to be human readable so like
if you have an ID for your your document
ID from your database like that's
auto-generated that's where you would
use the type ID when he gets parts it's
still a string but it's not something
that you're gonna be like printing out
to the screen so getting started with
graph QL server we declare all of our
types for different data so this is
actually a sample type from app react
native application that I've been
building so we declare the type with the
the key keyword type and then whatever
we want to name it you can name that
whatever you want and this is gonna look
really similar to like a JSON object
without all as much of the there's no
commas like and if you throw in commas
it'll yell at you
that might take a while touch me awhile
anyways I kept on trying to put commas
I'm like being a good good JavaScript
developer that it was so but similar to
JavaScript object the the keys on the
Left the values on the right so we've
got IB which is a type ID created at is
a type date so here we've got the
document ID from MongoDB because that's
the database that I'm using for the
project title is of type string and that
exclamation point says that that's an
honorable value so every brew entry must
have a title it cannot be null we also
can have subtypes so like JSON
architecture we're used to seeing like
objects within objects you can do that
with graph QL but you can't just say
like ingredients and then open up a new
object like it'll throw an error at you
you have to declare a separate type and
then you insert that so like type
ingredients is just another type just
like brew entry except it has the key
values of sugar water and tea which
actually is a further sub type so you
can nest them but you nest them a little
bit differently than traditional JSON
you can declare your own custom types so
you don't have to stick to the default
types that you come out of the box you
just have to say how they're serialize
and deserialize dan
database with graph QL declare that in
your schema and then you can use it
elsewhere
and you can also use enums or Union type
so like the brew method where it says
allowed brew methods that's an enum type
so it's only going to allow one of
several values so then we define our
queries which are in their own type
called query that's a reserved phrase
for setting up your queries in graph QL
and you declare the query name is key
and then you define what it returns so
here all brew entries returns an array
of type brew entry so they kind of build
up on each other you can also define
optional arguments again with the
appropriate types if you noticing
pattern types types types which where
this comes in in handy is with some - a
great tool that ships with called
graphical and built-in documentation and
you'll see why this is so amazing
a little bit so brew entry accepts the
singular argument and it's a required
argument because again we have that
exclamation point so it expects an ID
and it's gonna return a singular brew
entry you can also do mutations on our
database so here we've got new brew
entry and so we've got something a
little bit different here we have an
input type so input types are different
than regular types they're set up the
same except an input type is what is
declared inside those arguments so there
they're very similar like the brew entry
input is basically the same except it
doesn't have the ID field because
obviously there is no ID
it cannot be required because it has not
been saved to the database yet so nuber
entries gonna expect a brew entry input
it's going to return a brew entry up the
brew entry is gonna take the ID and the
input returned in the brew entry and
then we're moving
it's gonna take the ID and delete it so
there's a lot to digest and we still
haven't even well how does all of this
actually hook up like huh kombucha yes I
I'm like a true hipster Portlander so
schema is only half of the half of the
things with graph QL and setting up the
server you also need to have resolvers
and so resolvers basically tell the
server what in the world that's supposed
to do with this data structure so we set
up our resolvers and an object map and
we've got p root values such as query
and mutation so in that object we have
okay all brew entries is going to return
brew entry dot find brew entries a
mongoose model that I have set up
mutation is gonna take in the new brew
entry it's gonna take in the arguments
and return the saved output and I know
it's a node meetup but we still got to
talk about the client because this the
server is only half the excitement and
we're graph cool really shines is how it
integrates with front-end code so
out-of-the-box benefits is you get a
data store similar to redux without all
of the boilerplate by the way note
there's like next to no boilerplate
which is awesome there's been several
like large organizations that have
shifted from redux to graph QL and
eliminated very large portions of their
code base that was taken up with Redux
you get caching out of the box you don't
have any data massaging in the client
because you're declaring the data that
you want and that's all the data that
you're getting back you're not getting
you're not under fetching you're not
over fetching you're getting exactly the
data that you want back and so you don't
have to massage it on the clients end
again you can get exactly the data that
you need for each view so for
that blogpost index if all I want is the
title of the slug and an excerpt I'll
ask for is that and that's all I get you
can focus on more developer-friendly and
discoverable methods then a plethora of
end points yeah you've got that one end
point and you've got a really
discoverable API and you have an amazing
tool set to help write queries faster so
here's an example of the query syntax in
the client side you open up with a set
of brackets call the query open up
another set of brackets and say okay I
want the ID in the title that's going to
return a data object the root the root
key on that is going to be the query
name and again it returns an array of
brew entries in each one is only giving
me the ID and title because that's a
last four so we're gonna go into the
Star Wars API and bump that up a lot so
here's what is like one of the most
mind-blowing things ever
so graphical which is not a typo it is
graphical because apparently the people
who made it were very tongue-in-cheek
includes this docs tab and the ships
with any like graph QL at least with any
of the major frameworks that are
implementing it and if I pull this open
the Star Wars API doesn't allow me to
mutate their data so I only have this
query so I can click on this query and
now I can see oh here are here's the all
films query and oh it takes an argument
of after can give me in the description
hmm vehicles you can just drill down
into your API and see what everything
looks like
and as my schema changes that
automatically updates because it's
driven and produced by the schema so
there's no manually updating of
documentation there's no out-of-date
documentation you can deprecated certain
fields on your graph QL schema you can
include notes of why it was deprecated
you can include descriptions like you
get all that out of the box so we'll
just open up a query and we're gonna say
okay I want all films and we'll open
that up and another nice thing is if I
hit control space I can see okay I want
edges and know they're using relay which
has this edges a node concept and I can
say oh I want the title and I want the
release date and you can just start
playing around with it character
connection
Edge's you can build up really complex
queries we'll just run this oh here's
all the data that I get back and what's
really cool is since it's just a
specification it this nasty URL is
actually encoding this query so I could
plug in this URL like even if I didn't
want to set up a graph QL client in my
front-end code I could plug in that URL
into a fetch call and I'm gonna get
exactly that data object back really
cool also this is exactly the the format
that I need in my front end code so I
always test my queries in graphical test
my mutations get it working right rather
than having to navigate through three
different screens
oair didn't get this data back the way
you want and no I'm gonna do right here
I'm gonna get the instantaneous feedback
get it right and then just copy the code
over it's fantastic so here's some
resources and the length of the slides
is at the bottom how to graph QL comm is
a great video tutorial series built by
the folks at graph pool now Prisma which
do a database as a service and will do
your like they can set up they do a
sequel database and you can just say
okay here's the data set that I want and
how I want it set up
they'll like Auto create a lot of your
schemas and your resolvers for you you
can plug-in authentication they'll set
it all up for you I mean you're paying a
service fee but they do have some free
tiers if you just want to tinker around
with it and they also did release an
open source library if you want to
basically use their technology but
not have as many of the bells and
whistles but run it on your own servers
graph QL org is the specification page
graph dot cool we just talked about
graph QL stack is that reference I was
talking about earlier where you can
someone like took the time and bless
them for it and went through all the
different types of whether you're doing
backend server this front-end what
language you're writing in and you just
do a drop down and it'll say oh well
here's the if you're writing in Python
on backend server here's the frameworks
if you're writing an elixir if you're
it's amazing
Apollo graph QL I think is one of the
best JavaScript frameworks they have
both an express server and a client
server they're continuing to iterate on
and doing really well with I love
collecting graph QL links because it's
kind of a passion of mine so that's my
pin board with all of my graphical tags
and if you're interested in checking out
the kombucha log application that I'm
building it is on github although it's
not being as actively developed now that
I'm working full time
so all right well thank you so much
[Applause]
[Music]
you